in the next variation that we consider
the random variable theta is still
discrete so it might for example
represent a number of alternative
hypotheses but now the observation is
continuous of course we do have a
variation of the Bayes rule that's
applicable to this situation the only
difference from the previous version of
the Bayes rule is that now the PMF of X
the unconditional and the conditional
one is replaced by a PDF otherwise
everything remains the same a standard
example is the following
here we are sending a signal that takes
one of let's say three alternative
values and what we observe is the signal
that was sent plus some noise and the
typical assumption here might be that
the noise has zero mean and a certain
variance and is independent from the
signal that was sent this is an example
that we more or less studied some time
ago actually at that time we looked at
an example where theta could only take
one out of two values but the
calculations and the methodology remains
essentially the same as for the case of
three values so in principle we do know
at this point how to apply the Bayes
rule in this situation to come up with a
conditional pmf of theta and the key to
that calculation was that the term that
we need the conditional PDF of X can be
obtained from this equation as follows
if I tell you the value of theta then X
is essentially the same as W plus a
certain constant adding a constant just
shifts the PDF of W by an amount equal
to that constant and therefore the
conditional PDF of X is the shifted PDF
of the random variable W using this
particular fact we can then apply the
Bayes rule carry out the calculations
and suppose that in the end we came up
with these results that is we obtain the
specific observation X and based on that
observation we calculate the conditional
probabilities of the different choices
of theta
at this point we may use the map rule
and come up with an estimate which is
the value of theta which is the more
likely one and then we can continue
exactly as in the case of discrete
measurements of discrete observations
and talk about conditional probabilities
of error and so on now the fact that X
is continuous really makes no difference
once we arrive at this picture with the
map rule we still choose the most likely
value of theta and this is our estimate
and we can calculate the probability of
error which for the map rule would be
point for exactly the same argument as
for the case of discrete observation
supplies and shows that this conditional
probability of error is smallest under
the map rule and then we can continue
similarly and talk about the overall
probability of error which can be
calculated using the total probability
theorem in two ways one way is to take
the conditional probability over Ferrer
for any given value of text and then
average those conditional probabilities
of error over all the possible choices
of X because X is now continues here
we're going to have an integral
alternatively you can condition on the
possible values of theta calculate
conditional probabilities of error for
any particular choice of theta and then
take a weighted average of them in
practice this calculation sometimes
turns out to be the simpler one finally
we can replicate the argument that we
had in the discrete case since the map
rule makes this term here as small as
possible it is less than or equal to the
probability of error that you would get
under any other estimate or estimator
then it follows that the integral will
also be as small as possible and
therefore the conclusion is that the
overall probability of error is again
the smallest possible when we use the
map rule
and so the map rule remains the optimal
way of choosing between alternative
hypotheses whether X is discrete or
continuous